on va parler du tourisme et notamment de
la sur fréquentation touristique face à
2,7 sur fréquentation les sites naturels
font l'objet d'une protection renforcée
on va en parler longuement mais d'abord
on va voir avec vous alex le point et
des différentes solutions qui sont mises
en oeuvre nous et rien alors d'abord on
peut dire que ces sites sont protégés
par la loi et par des arrêtés au niveau
national le dernier date de 2018 et
dresse la liste de 150 sites qui
rentrent dans la catégorie des habitats
naturels protégés qui sont menacés par
la sur fréquentation touristique parmi
eux par exemple il ya la dune du pilat
le cirque de gavarnie dans les pyrénées
les calanques de marseille ou encore le
mont blanc et sur ses sites classés si
en touriste est coupable de la
dégradation il encourt une peine de
prison de trois ans et une amende de
cent cinquante mille euros donc c'est
assez dissuasif alors ça c'est pour la
législation au niveau national alex les
collectivités locales elles mettent en
oeuvre des mesures pour protéger les
sites de ceinture fréquentation louis a
beaucoup d'initiatives de la part des
collectivités prenons l exemple d'abord
à d'étretat et de ses célèbres falaises
pour information à la commune d'être
tassé 1400 habitants mais qui accueille
et bien un million de touristes par an
donc le site est très vite saturé cela
met en danger le site et son équilibre
naturel par jour 300 kg de galets sont
ramassés par les touristes à être ta et
disparaissent ce qui fragilise ce
littoral donc la commune à trouver une
solution c'est d'arrêter toute campagne
de promotion adea falaises d'étretat on
appelle ça le ad marketing et donc le
maire d'etretat a demandé à l'office de
tourisme de ne publier publié une seule
photo des falaises pour diminuer
diminuer un petit peu l afflux
touristique autre solution intéressant
qui est notamment utilisé par la région
sud paca philippe tabarot c'est de
conclure des contrats avec les
applications de navigation a-gps
justement pour orienter les touristes ou
pas sur ces sites qui sont
désorienté ou en tout cas leur
conseiller d'aller sur ces sites à des
heures de moindre fréquentation par
exemple en fin de journée donc le gps
qui est bien participe aussi de ce
tourisme durable ensuite il ya des
solutions qui sont beaucoup plus
radicale et efficace comme la jauge
c'est à dire interdire l'accès au site
au delà d'un certain nombre de personnes
c'est ce qui se fait désormais sur l'île
de porquerolles avec une jauge de 6000
personnes par jour pour accéder sur
cette île de 12 kilomètres carrés un
site protégé qui accueillait auparavant
le double douze mille personnes par jour
et une jauge qui l'a aussi fait l'objet
d'une initiative d'un accord entre les
collectivités métropole de toulon
commune de hyères et puis le parc
national et on finit dans la même
logique avec le système de réservation
c'est ce qu'il était c'est ce qui a été
décidé pour accéder au mont blanc il
faut désormais réserver une place dans
les deux refuges du mont blanc ce qui
fait seulement 214 places par jour mais
ça permet de préserver le site avec des
contrôles de gendarmes des contrôles de
brigade municipale 1 la brigade blanche
du mont blanc qui un contrôle les
différents touristes qui se rendent sur
le site qui contrôle aussi des activités
un seul de ski et à l'alpinisme sont
autorisés désormais car avant il ya eu
des abus de la part des touristes avec
notamment en 2019 et bien touristes
anglais qui étaient venus sur le mont
blanc avec son rameur pour faire du
rameur sur le toit de l'europe et qu'ils
l'avaient laissée sur place donc voilà
maintenant c'est réglementation permet
d'éviter ce type de comportement des
touristes
un exemple vous savez parfaitement
résumé la situation les différents
moyens qui existent pour les pour les
mères ou pour les autorités pour
réglementer certains sites à la fois
pour des questions environnementales
quelquefois pour des questions de
sécurité particulièrement importante
alors on en parlera il faut revenir
aussi à la base de se dire que c'est
plutôt une bonne chose de nouveau qu'on
puisse parler d'eux sur fréquentation
pas d'hyper fréquentation mais deux sur
fréquentation parce que le domaine du
tourisme a connu une crise terrible avec
l'aco vide une crise qui a été
historique
et ta ble ment et qui a mis en péril
beaucoup d'économies qui sont autour du
tourisme moi dans ma région sud vous
l'avez dit le tourisme c'est 20
milliards environ de recettes par an les
alpes-maritimes reçoivent 13 millions de
visiteurs par an une commune que je
connais bien la commune de cannes 50 %
pratiquement de son produit intérieur
brut vient du tourisme donc il ne faut
pas oublier ça je pense que ces essais
la base d'un autre côté toutes les
mesures que vous avez pu annoncer et
peut-être il faudrait rajouter une ppl
qui a été votée dans cette maison par le
sénateur bignon en 2010 neuf et qui est
dans la navette actuellement permet de
donner des pouvoirs supplémentaires aux
maires pour pouvoir réglementer certains
sites notamment sur la base de ses
pouvoirs de police et de la question de
la laisser
et après dans le cadre d'un contentieux
c'est toujours assez difficile il faut
que cela se soit bien bordé
juridiquement sur les notions d'ordre
public de tranquillité publique eu de
pollution potentielles et le sénat
avaient est en train d'agir sur ces
questions également pour donner un
arsenal au maire mais je veux bien qu'on
repart du principe de se dire que le
tourisme est une chance pour notre pays
est une chance pour ma région et pour
autant il faut justement pouvoir
sanctuariser un certain nombre de sites
les entretenir et les mesures qui sont
prises que ce soit par les territoires
ou par l'état sur certains endroits dits
exceptionnels et en sueur ou plutôt en
hyper fréquentation sont indispensables
et parmi ces collectivités qui ont pris
des mesures et ces élus qui ont pris des
mesures et les élus de la collectivité
territoriale de corse collectivités qui
a instauré des quotas à partir de cet
été pour limiter l'accès à trois sites
sensibles ça vient de chiens nous emmène
sur l'un d'entre eux ce sont les il
avait sud de l'île regarde
c'est le joyau de la réserve naturelle
des bouches de bonifacio
lille l'avait dit est un petit paradis
très convoité jean michel gault you lie
et son équipe sont chargés de la
protéger
monsieur c'est une zone interdite à
l'ancrage dans des temps que la main
vous devez jeter l'ancré dans les zones
de sable entre les bouées jaunes
dont les années 70 lille est payé 400
personnes par an aujourd'hui 290 1000
touristes viennent chaque année y passer
la journée bonjour à tous vous venez de
débarquer sur une zone de protection
renforcée des lavages c'est un espace
fragile et protégés c'est pour cette
raison qu'il ya des règles très strictes
à respecter donc dans un premier temps
je vous demandais de rester uniquement
sur les sentiers et les plages et
uniquement sur lino principal pour
protéger ce site fragile l'assemblée de
corse a décidé de limiter sa
fréquentation à 2000 personnes maximum
par jour un quota fixé par un conseil
scientifique qui doit permettre à terme
de ramener le nombre de visiteurs à 150
mille personnes par an d'ici 2030 on n'a
que neuf mille mètres carrés de plage
donc on peut permettre un boeuf dans un
oeuf et on peut pas mettre 4000 5000
personnes par jour ici c'est pas
possible vous avez forcément des
infractions vous avez forcément un
dérangement qui est important et donc il
ya de toute façon à une
une limitation qui est qui est aussi
quantitatif cela fait plus de trente ans
que jean michel culioli travail à la
préservation de lille l'avait dit un
petit bout de terre de 69 hectares où
certaines espèces d'oiseaux protégés
viennent se reproduire et il sait
exactement où trouver leur nid depuis
façon dorée qui nichent en dessous c'est
à sa famille de des albatros c'est la
plus grande colonie de de méditerranée
nord occidentale
ils viennent se reproduire sur ces
rochers ils ont besoin de tranquillité
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir assurer la la
couvaison et puis après l'élevage des
jeunes lille lavezzi abrite aussi des
plantes uniques comme le leem union
lambie denis les sentiers ne suffisent
pas toujours à la protégée du
piétinement il faut qu'on puisse avoir
un petit sentier qui soit juste qui soit
juste à côté et encore une fois sur ce
petit sentier on peut pas mettre 300
personnes en même pas un côté donc il
faut qu'on ait un moment donné une
véritable réflexion sur la canalisation
mais aussi sur la quantification et donc
sur la notion à quelques mètres des
sentiers de randonnée les touristes qui
profitent des eaux cristallines n'ont
pas entendu parler de ces quotas
pourtant déjà en vigueur et accueillent
plutôt bien la nouvelle il ya
malheureusement oui des déchets des
déchets sur l'île devant le cimetière
devant donc des sites qui sont quand
même normalement protégées et je pense
que ce serait bien que ce soit mis en
place pour justement éviter tout ça on
est venu à quelques années et en effet
il y avait moins de moins de bateaux un
petit peu moins de monde
qui est qui et des cottages je pense
qu'à terme ça serait une bonne chose un
peu moins enthousiaste les bateliers qui
amène les touristes sur l'île n'ont pas
souhaité s'exprimer
aujourd'hui les retours sur les l'avait
dit cook 37 euros privé d'une partie de
leurs recettes les transporteurs
pourraient bien augmenter ce prix un
risque assumé par le maire de bonifacio
lille avait dit appartient à la ville
ici la quasi totalité des habitants vit
du tourisme
la priorité c'est permettre aux
bonifacien qui le désirent de pouvoir
aller sur l'île et de façon plus large
je dirais aux corses ensuite évidemment
nous entendons sur les chiffres qui ont
été avancés laisser une part importante
je dirais à aux touristes et je crois
que là aussi il faut pas se voiler la
face nous irons vers une politique
tarifaire peut-être plus importante qui
permettra aussi peut-être à la
collectivité de corse et à la commune de
bonifacio de tirer aussi la dea des
moyens pour pouvoir continuer à
entretenir et à mettre en valeur ce
patrimoine exceptionnel si
l'expérimentation est concluante la
politique de quotas testé cette année
sur trois sites sensibles corse pourrait
bien être appliqué plus largement sur
l'île de beauté est alors vous comprenez
cette décision de la collectivité
territoriale de corse d'instaurer des
quotas ou et je peux le comprendre par
rapport à ce qu'on a dit à la question
si je n'ai pas abordé tout à l'heure
mais de la biodiversité inquiets qui est
une vraie question sur sur ces sites
existent la bête et on le voit la
question de la sécurité on en parlera
tout à l'heure je pense avec les
calandres cas à marseille bref yahia ces
données en dehors de l' hyper
fréquentation qui peut exister et ça a
été très justement dit il ya un juste
équilibre à avoir entre la tranquillité
également d'aider des riverains
des personnes qui peuvent comprendre
qu'il ya besoin d'une activité
touristique de développement économique
de manière indispensable mais mais
jusqu'à quand on a deux phénomène assez
récent finalement qui ont fait qu'il
n'ya plus de régulation aujourd'hui
notamment avec tous les vols low cost
qui ont été multipliés et qui font que
nos aéroports en terme de fréquentation
sont pas en train d'exploser et avant
vous aviez une moyenne de réguler par
rapport à la capacité hôtelière
aujourd'hui vous avez le développement
d'un certain nombre de plateformes comme
airbnb qui font que les capacités
hôtelières traditionnels sont largement
augmenté et il y à de grandes
difficultés à pouvoir contenir ce flux
pour les raisons qu'on a évoqué donc je
pense que c'est bien le trouver un juste
équilibre entre
préservation des sites et développement
économique et touristique de sites qui
sont remarquables et on ne peut pas
peut-être aller en corse en voir saisi
je le comprends très bien pour les
touristes encore faut-il qu'ils aient un
juste équilibre et qu'on revoie
peut-être notre manière de voir le
tourisme via de nouvelles notions qui
existent d'écotourisme de slow tourisme
en bon français
voilà donc à développer on va aller voir
ses fans ses fans comment ça se passe
dans la région protège on a vu dans ce
reportage évidemment il ya une cet
équilibre comme le dit philippe tabarot
compliqué à trouver entre d'un côté la
préservation de la biodiversité et de
l'autre les bateliers par exemple qui ne
sont pas contents effectivement de
l'instauration de ces quotas c'est
compliqué à gérer tout ça bah oui en
tout cas on comprend bien lorsque l'on
voit les labels ce que c'est un
territoire qu'il faut protéger c'est le
même tempo en région bretagne également
parce qu'il y a pour l'année dernière 14
millions de visiteurs sur cette année ça
donne 90 millions de nuitées 80 mille
emplois directs mais il faut quand même
protégé j'entendais tout à l'heure un
peu horrifiée légal et qui parle qui
partait de dés des plages de normandie
c'est complètement incroyable mais
lorsque vous êtes dans le département du
morbihan devant ce site vraiment
mégalithique incroyable des alignements
de carnac à carnac et à la trinité eh
bien vous avez été obligé est bien de
mettre des délits vraiment des des
protections pour que les gens ne
viennent pas alors c'est difficile de
repartir avec un mini reçurent son dos
mais pour que les les touristes ne
viennent pas au fur et à mesure alors
que c'est pour la bonne cause c'est
faire une photo mais ne viennent pas
dégradé idem vraiment sur le la pointe
du raz 200 et art magnifique au fin fond
de cette bretagne le bout du monde là
aussi il y a eu des des chemins qui ont
été balisés réglementée déjà parce que
c'est très dangereux mais aussi pour
faire très attention à cette
biodiversité audi beaucoup en bretagne
que lorsque vous revenez partout
d'ailleurs lorsque vous retournez à un
rocher alors ça fait plaisir on familles
aux enfants il faut remettre ce rocher
exactement à la même place sinon vous
allez complètement désorganisée puis je
dirais très vite pour parler des îles
parce que les îles du ponant ce sont de
véritables joyaux delhi le droit ou et
sans molène là aussi il faut faire très
attention il ya eu énormément d'action
en direction de l'électrique sur ces
îles aujourd'hui vous pouvez louer des
vélos électriques des des petites
voiturettes électriques des scooters
électriques
il ya beaucoup de choses aussi en
direction d des déchets parce qu'il ya
eu un moment où les îles qui recevait un
peu comme à la baisse des bateaux tout
au long de la journée eh bien venez
mettre à mal un véritable joyau doc là
aussi en bretagne la protection du
littoral mais le tourisme il est
également en intérieur lorsque vous
laisse vous allez dans les monts d'arrée
c'est un spectacle magnifique mais là
aussi qu'il faut protéger la protection
c'est véritablement le maître mot en
région bretagne commune sur toutes les
régions touristiques ouais notamment en
région sud 1 provence alpes côte d'azur
où on va aller puisque vous parlez des
calanques philippe tabarot on va
retrouver gilles aymeric avis quel
directeur de rédaction de la provence
bon jean guilhem merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous un jour matin guilhem dans
votre région aussi il ya eu des
limitations l'accès aux calanques est
limité
oui à titre expérimental ça a été lancée
le 26 juin dernier dans deux cas langue
du parc national des calanques la
calanque de sugiton qui est sans doute
l'une des plus pittoresques et l'une des
plus fréquentées la calanque des pierres
tombées qui elle aussi attire beaucoup
de monde figurez vous que dans ces
calanques en enregistré l'été dernier
jusqu'à 2500 personnes par jour c'est
trop beaucoup trop disent des experts
parce que cela provoque un phénomène
d'érosion parce que les gens marchent
tout autour de ces calanques et donc
l'accès a été limité à 400 personnes par
jour et par calanques il faut donc
s'inscrire au préalable les inscriptions
sont gratuites elles se font en ligne
on peut les faire trois jours avant la
date de visite et jusqu'à la veille 18
heures et seuls les heureux élus seules
les personnes inscrites peuvent
désormais les fréquenter les gens pour
le moment se prête plutôt bien à cette
mesure accepte cette idée là accepte
cette règle là parce qu'ils ont
conscience que dans ce périmètre du parc
des calanques qui a été créée il ya tout
juste dix ans et bien la nature
l'environnement est très fragile et que
donc on ne peut pas faire ce que l'on
veut ça c'est un point important vous le
disiez aussi tout à l'heure pas très
loin de marseille un petit peu plus loin
quand même dans le var du côté d'hyères
ce sens et bien les îles de porquerolles
de porquerolles là aussi on est dans le
périmètre d'un parc il y avait douze
mille visiteurs par jour qui arrivait
sur l'île de porquerolles et la jauge a
été fixé à 6000 personnes maximum là
aussi ça a été fait dans le cadre d'un
accord avec les bateliers qui ont eux
aussi accepté et bien de jouer le jeu
parce qu'ils ont conscience que à force
de trop fréquenter ces lieux là est bien
le risque c'est qu'à terme plus personne
ne puisse y aller oriane merci beaucoup
pour ce point guilhem directeur des
rédactions de la provence philippe
tabarot évidemment une réaction cc
d'après ce que nous dit qu'il aime c'est
plutôt bien pris finalement c'est plutôt
bien accepté du côté des calanques oui
j'ai l'impression que les échos on peut
avoir deux de ces deux initiatives
fonctionne plutôt bien et permettez moi
aussi comme tout le monde a parlé de ces
îles de parler des îles de lérins par
des alpes-maritimes avec une expérience
thornhill vous avez raison exactement
assez intéressante
ce sont les moines de lille 2 les races
de l'île saint-honorat qui ont été les
premiers à réguler peut-être puisqu'ils
ont décidé de récupérer
l'accès à à lille à travers des
compagnies de bateliers comme vous les
avez appelé et qui gère maintenant
directement l'accompagné alors à la fois
ça leur procure des recettes
supplémentaires qui leur permet de d'un
vestiaire sur sur l'île et puis de
contrôler totalement au niveau du
transport
l'accès à l'île ce qui leur permet aussi
de pouvoir continuer à vivre leur
spiritualité à travailler le cas échéant
et à faire leur excellent vin qui est
exporté dans le monde entier et sur
l'autre île qui appartient à la ville de
cannes l'île sainte-marguerite il ya une
initiative intéressante qui a été prise
concernant les déchets ou là les
visiteurs sont dans l'obligation à la
fin de la journée de repartir avec leurs
déchets sur
sur la commune donc voilà on s'aperçoit
que chacun s'organise un petit peu en
fonction de sa spécificité mais que
l'esprit est le même la protection du
site la régulation tout en gardant
un aspect économique et touristique est
indispensable pour nos territoires
est-ce qu'il ya aussi un enjeu de
régulation au sein d'un territoire passe
quand on pense à hacher vous évidemment
on pense à la côte d'azur on pense à la
mer mais il ya aussi un magnifique
arrière pays niçois est ce que l'enjeu
aussi c'est de réguler de tête repoussé
les touristes vers ces zones plus
rurales et plus seulement vers les
littoraux oui on a la chance dans notre
département d'avoir la mer et la
montagne comme on comme on dit à
proximité et on n'a pas parlé de tout ce
qui touche au parc notamment national du
mercantour qui est à quelques km de la
mer est là aussi depuis un certain
nombre d'années il ya une protection une
vigilance particulièrement accrue des
responsables du parc pour que le
tourisme puisse se vivre pleinement et
de profiter de ses paysages
exceptionnels
historique mais d'un autre côté de
pouvoir les préserver et avec une
surveillance qui est forte avec des
sanctions qui sont très pénalisante mais
qui sont indispensables pour pouvoir
maintenir ces sites exceptionnels que
nous avons hérité de notre histoire et
que nouveau devant garder dans le
meilleur état possible pour les
transmettre aux jeunes générations
[Musique]